let's Glen start man I'm pressing on
stark men who is has been a case Western
for 20-plus years now won t phony five
years celebrating his golden not what is
a diamond silver silver whatever it is
it's an important one and he's really a
foundational player in the world of CMB
cosmology and studies of the early
universe and he has sort of an
intellectual peripatetic ism I guess if
that's a word that really he's done
everything from high-energy particle
physics to topology of the universe you
hear about today really fundamental
issues that we take for granted you know
is the universe a doughnut you know that
would make Homer Simpson really happy
but it may or may not be the case
topologically not geometrically we know
a lot about the geometry but what is it
to say about the topology we learn about
that and he's also really involved with
with sort of fundamental questions about
whether the universe has anomalous spots
and anomalous patterns was a great book
by Gen eleven called how the universe
got its spots it's also related to
topology but in Glens case he works on
really anomalous anomalies whether or
not we understand why the universe has
strange patterns in the temperature and
now in the polarization of the Cosmic
Microwave Background so he's here today
he was an undergrad at UT Toronto right
right he's actually a Canadian and he's
heading heading back to heading to the
East Coast for a Symons workshop on
fundamental physics he was a PhD student
of Demopolis at Stanford and then he got
the Case Western that literally the year
or so after I left and so I missed out
on his educational prowess but I'll sit
in your lap don't worry it's great to
see the turnout and you know before
classes actually start and and I want to
extend our gratitude for having Glenn
come all the way out here that Southern
California basically to give this talk
and hang out with our Curt Thank You
Glenn thank you very much Brian it's a
pleasure to be here
it's been a long time since I was there
in San Diego and I always never forget
how beautiful with this but but in fact
I want to say that the North Coast is
also a very
very beautiful place woman's up here
like a couple people of asking where's
Cleveland so it's up here on Lake Erie
and you know you have a lot of salt
water but a large fraction of fresh
water that's not frozen the set of lakes
and here's on the pretty much the
southernmost part of the Great Lakes it
has an important physics history because
this is this is where the first really
important experiment in American science
American physics at least was done the
michelson-morley experiment just outside
my building that's my building when it
was built back when the Rockefellers
came from Cleveland and made all their
money there and this is what the area
looks like now with one of the best art
museums in the country there and
arguably the best into the orchestra in
the country and so my build this
building sits right about here and it
looked just like this except it's
actually red it's not black and white
those of you who like newer music this
is the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame Museum
which is dips down the street and of
course the other place that got a really
really interesting building is our
management school so all right so what I
want to talk about is the possibility
that there are loops around the cosmos
because yes what I want to do is pick up
on this point that Bryan made which is
that we know a lot about the geometry of
the universe but not very much about the
topology so I think you'd all agree that
if I took this piece of paper and drew a
triangle on it and I measured the angles
about that triangle that they would add
up to 180 degrees to find and I think
you'd agree that doing that if I roll
that up and I went and measured those
angles since those are all local
measurements they'd be exactly the same
and they'd still add up to PI and so it
doesn't look like it because in order to
roll it up I had to use
third dimension but if I was living in
this space it's still a flat space I
haven't changed the local geometry
anywhere but I have changed the topology
because now there are short cuts around
the universe and it's much harder to do
in three dimensions but I could take
this and glue it on to that side and
then I would get what's called the two
torus and it would still be true there
that some of the angles of the triangles
would be 180 degrees so we've learned a
lot about whether we live in a space
that looks like this like in which the
sum of angles the triangle is 180
degrees and the question is what do we
know about this these other properties
about the topology of the universe so
just to give you a sense if we live in
such a universe a universe in which
let's say the fundamental domain was a
cube and those we knew imagined we'd
live on the interior of a cube in which
the left and right hand side are
identified like old video games the back
and front and the top and bottom you
know we would sit here at in the earth
and we'd look out and see another earth
and the other ass all around us and
there's be this whole pattern of objects
as I said the world may not be flat and
though some of the angles of triangle
may not be 180 degrees it may be bigger
like if we lived on a positively curved
space or negative like if we lived on a
negatively curved space and the same
questions stand no matter what the
geometry is so for example here is a
fundamental domain in which you can make
identifications and this example works
only in positively curved space and so
in in positively curved space we can
also have non-trivial topology so that
works fearful topology is kind of an odd
thing because that many of you have
heard the expression that to a
topologist a doughnut is the same as a
coffee cup so how can i connect geometry
and topology well a fellow named Bill
Thurston came out with a conjecture back
in the 1980s very famous conjecture
which was proved by Pearlman in 2003 and
what it says is that every closed so if
I
a finite space that has three dimensions
and it's a manifold which means it has
certain smoothness properties then I can
always take that and divide it into
pieces each of which emits one of only
eight homogeneous t'me geometries and
those are flat 3-dimensional space
positively curved 3-dimensional space
negatively curved in three-dimensional
space
positively curved two-dimensional space
cross cross flat one dimensional space
negatively curved two-dimensional space
cross flat one dimensional space and
then these three other things I have no
idea what they're okay but we don't
worry about them usually in in cosmology
in fact usually we don't worry about the
we worry only about the first three we
can try to worry about the next two but
there really are very good limits on
anisotropic curvature okay but certainly
these three actually it's being the last
three if you look at them the geometry
doesn't seem to have anything to do with
the universe remember so we can take
space up whatever it is face whatever it
is and carve it up into pieces at least
each of which have one of these
geometries I told and I always worry now
when I listen to cut apologists tell me
things because it turns out that they
mean different things than we do
I'm told that generically you only end
up with one piece okay so most
3-manifolds have one piece whatever most
of these and those pieces are one of
these eight and we're going to focus on
these three but certainly we could think
about these other two as well how as two
cross bar how's that up genius it's it's
homogeneous but it's not as a trauma
answers right it's a it's an anisotropic
space the curvature is is it's flat in
one dimension and the other two it's
positively curved and it's there's quite
good limits about that basically what
would happen is that the first peak
would move around depending where you
were looking on the sky in the same
um this is uh so this is another tiling
pattern another fundamental domain that
works only in hyperbolic space all right
so we're used to looking for the
curvature of the universe how do we do
that we go out and measure the
temperature and I'm gonna assume that
everyone here knows about the Cosmic
Microwave Background and walking to give
you an introduction to CMB but I will
remind you what we learn in cosmology
kindergarten which is that when you
measure the temperature of the microwave
background on the sky what you're
instructed to do is to then go and do a
spherical harmonic expansion and figure
out what the coefficients of the
spherical harmonics are and our standard
model for the fluctuations around the
mean temperature I wrote I wrote delta T
here I mean T that means I'm going to
sum over only ELLs bigger than zero so
I'm taking out the average temperature
the standard model for those
fluctuations is that the sky is what we
call statistically isotropic there's no
special directions statistically and
that these al M's
these are realizations of independent
Gaussian random variables you notice
there's some abstract ensemble out there
that these are drawn from which is
Gaussian and if I if I look at a LM and
some other ll prime and M prime and I
asked one way expect from the product of
ALM and L prime M prime star I expect
zero unless L equals L Prime and M
equals M prime and then I get my
expectation is some number C sub L which
only depends on L and not ad and that
that part's the statistical I saw three
and if that's our theory and our theory
that four tells us that what we really
want to do the only really interesting
thing to do at least effort to leading
order is to figure out what these C sub
ELLs are in the underlines here and and
all of the information interesting
information is contained in these CC
bells
which are the average of the sum over m
of alm squared now how do we go about
and then and use that to measure the
curvature of the universe we notice that
there is a fundamental scale embedded in
the early universe which is the fact
that that sound is traveling through the
early universe and it can only travel a
certain distance so there's a sound
horizon at the moment when the microwave
background is released and the photons
can travel and the size of that sound
horizon the angular size of that on the
sky is different depending on whether
the triangle that it forms here we are
looking out at it we see some some kusik
wave and the angle of that triangle will
be different depending on whether the
sums and angles of triangles is 180
degrees or more than 30 degrees or less
and that will mean that this peak in the
angular power spectrum what I'm plotting
here are these sisa bells that I told
you all of the information information
in these sisa bells so here's the
pattern that they that the theory tells
us it should have and where exactly
these Peaks are depend on the curvature
and it'll be someplace if the universe
has flat geometry it'll be somewhere
else but it's positively curved geometry
somewhere else if it was negatively
curved home when g isotropic german
geometry and if it had anisotropic
geometry would be in different places in
different parts of the sky and somewhere
around about 2000 people were able to
measure that and found an answer
consistent with it being flat now things
are a little bit more complicated maybe
today you know almost 20 years later
where they're consistent with it being
flat but depending on how you look at it
maybe there's some evidence of weak
evidence that we actually live in a
possibility curved universe I mean if
you just look at the evidence from the
CMB you find that the the Omega and
curvature a thinking of it is an energy
density it isn't but they that there's
that there's some evidence for negative
curve for positive curvature right
but if you add in other other
contributions to other types of data
that evidence goes away and and probably
this is all connected to the tension
over the over the Hubble constant as
well okay so these are at the level of
you know it used to be that in cosmology
without we would argue over factors of
two then over ten percent and now we're
on our being over you know a couple of
percent right it's just a different
version of right so what about topology
so that does this long history of
looking for the curvature of the
universe what about looking for topology
well that goes back even before general
relativity Schwarzschild thought about
it the sitter thought about a
topologically non-trivial version of
Einstein's s positively curved is s3
universe almost immediately after
Einstein came out with his original
cosmology and kind of episodic you know
kick irregularly ever since then people
have thought a little bit about topology
so how do you go about looking for
topology and the first thing you think
of is I remember I said I showed you
that beautiful picture of the earth you
know there's a if I'm sitting here
there's another copy of the earth over
there and another one behind it and some
more so why not go look at say for
objects that that are repeat it you know
so for example I see Einstein here and I
go look out somewhere over there and I
should see another copy of Einstein well
the problem is if you think about it
depending on where you're looking you're
gonna see those objects at different
distances and then therefore at
different times in the past and if so
you may look close by and you see
Einstein as you know that's at one age
and you look for the other direction you
you see him at an earlier age and you
have to recognize that those are in fact
the exact same person right so I mean
look out and see some galaxies or some
quays
are over there and now I want to look
for it but I have to do that I have to
figure out what it would have looked
like at a different age and that's not
so easy
you also may not see it in the same
orientation in fact typically you won't
see them from the same orientation even
worse good chance if you're looking at
it from the front you're gonna see it
from the back so things may look
completely different and in fact it may
have even involved into a different
object right you may have had galaxy
mergers in the mean time so the object
that you're looking for may not be the
same object as it was but the evolution
or do you know predecessor of the object
that you're looking for so people have
tried to look for use object searches to
look for topology but it's really tough
because of this problem you have to
convince yourself that you really would
recognize the objects in the different
directions and so probably the most
promising place to look for topology is
in the Cosmic Microwave Background why
is that well probably the most important
thing is the CMB is all at the same
distance okay no matter which direction
you look the microwave the surface of
last scattering is two very good
approximation at the same distance and
so this idea that this worrying about
how things evolved that that piece of it
at least we take out now it's not the
case that we're going to take out the
fact that we're looking at things from
different sides so we're going to have
to figure out how that how that imprints
so there's three basic ways that we can
imagine looking for for topology in the
microwave address the first is to
remember where does it and they actually
all come from remembering where does the
microwave background come from what's
the what is producing these fluctuations
in the early universe well those are
those are all the imprints of sound
waves that have been traveling through
the universe acoustic waves they've been
traveling through the universe for four
hundred thousand years we believe that
the origin of those sound waves is that
there were a scalar field we call it the
influence
on and that had fluctuations that were
generated quantum mechanically and so we
are looking at excitations of the eigen
modes of that scalar field the imprints
of that and if we change our space
change the boundary conditions of our
space impose periodic boundary
conditions topological boundary
conditions we're going to change the
spectrum of modes well we're going to
change the eigen modes entirely they're
no longer going to be Fourier modes are
going to be super positions of Fourier
modes or the generalizations of those
two curved space so for one thing the
spectrum of modes will become discrete
don't be a long wavelengths cutoff
there'll be a wavelength beyond which
you can't get any modes if the universe
has is compact in all directions so
there's this idea that the spectrum is
the topology so if we could measure the
spectrum we would learn the topology in
fact there's a very famous question by
an algebra named Mark Katz can you hear
the shape of a drop and the answer is no
if you're a mathematician and what do I
mean well it's no one's precisely the
sense that a mathematician Ramin is that
there are counter examples there are
what I call ISO spectral drum so here
are the shapes of two drums that are
different that have exactly the same
spectrum of eigen modes and here are two
drums that are even more special which
is that the these two shaped drums which
are different if I strike this one here
and this one here I will get exactly the
same sound
they're called homophonic drums but
they're rare so generically if you take
two shape draw different shape drums you
can hear the difference between them and
so if you think about it what we're
really asking is can we hear the shape
of the universe because we're look we
have acoustic waves in the universe
we're trying to extract the spectrum of
eigen but of the eigenmodes
right the spectrum of the scalar wave
operator by looking at the acoustic
waves and others by listening to the
drum geometrical not topological well in
this case I impose zero boundary
conditions at the edge and a question
that hasn't been that there are all
sorts of mathematical questions that are
generalizations of this which haven't
been answered like what happens if it's
not zero bound you know but zero
boundary conditions but topological
boundary conditions what happens if you
don't have perfect ears right how much
information do you lose if you cut out
some of the low frequencies is the
information sitting in the low eigen
mode a low eigen frequencies or it's it
is it sitting in the infinite number of
high frequencies people don't know the
answers to those questions this it's
also not known how this depends on the
dimension so there's a hole I talked a
little bit to some peter Sarlacc at one
point who studies these kind of things
apparently there's all sorts of open
questions in this in this area that
aren't know so in principle one could
try very generic search to measure the
eigen modes and the eigen frequencies
and figure out what the what the eigen
spectrum is of the scalar wave operator
and that would tell us what the topology
is that's very challenging because we
only have one universe we only get to
measure it once at the moment we only
really get to measure it on the surface
of last scattering if we could do a
tomographic survey if we could look if
we could look at many many you know
concentric spheres out to the last
scattering surface and probably better
but ultimately maybe this is the way
we'll will nail down
another way to go is to compute what's
caca is to compute the correlation
function now we all we do this normally
we take pairs of points on the sky we
take the products of their temperature
we average over those and that will be
different in each space that will be
different in every in every different
manifold it can be worse than that it
can be different in different places in
every manifold okay so because these
spaces break homogeneity so but this is
one of the leading ways of trying to
look forward to Paulo G is to compute
the quality was the pixel pixel
correlation function the product of the
temperatures in different places on the
sky and compare it to what we what we
auctioned it compare that what we see to
what's expected actually you do this in
modal space not in pixel space so this
is one of the methods and then what
we've focused on over the last 20 years
is a way to do it see the challenge with
the challenge with this method is that
as I said what you expect from the pixel
pixel correlation function is different
in every single space and there is an
infinite number of different spaces to
look at which is challenging
computationally it's worth each of those
spaces many of those spaces have have up
to six real parameters to describe exact
you know exactly how they're configured
so for example I showed you a cube but
instead of showing you a cube as the
fundamental domain I could have showed I
could have stretched one of the sides to
the Sun a lot you know I could have
stretched one length of the Q made it
longer in one dimension the direction
than the other two okay I could also
tilt the cube you can get
parallelepipeds instead of rectangles
for the faces so so there's a there's
there's an awful lot of possibilities
and you worried that when you discover
one that fits the data better than then
note you know then the simple topology
that all you've done is paid a huge look
elsewhere penalty that you know that
that's hard to
had hard to overcome so what we did is
we took a different approach called
circles in the sky which is one that
doesn't care about what space you live
in and so think of yourself to
understand what that is let's go back to
this three tourists picture where we
live in a space that is a tiling of the
infinite Euclidean 3-space and so let's
let's take two neighboring earths and
imagine that we are on earth doing a
microwave background experiment and that
means that we have we are looking at
light that is coming from the last
gathering surface and that last
gathering surfaces centered on us of
course there's nothing special about our
location anyone anywhere if they did a
microwave background experiment will be
getting photons from their last
scattering surface which would be a
sphere centered on them so here we are
going down to let's say my fine chili on
here no I can't because it's turned the
wrong way okay so we're going to go down
to the South Pole and we're going to do
a microwave background experiment right
and we're gonna have a last scattering
surface and and so so is this copy of us
over here I'm gonna do a laugh
scatterings going to do a CMB experiment
and they're gonna have a last scattering
surface and if if our nearest copy is
close enough then those last scattering
surfaces are going to intersect and
here's my last scattering surface I look
out here's here's me over here I look at
my last gathering surface and if those
last scattering surfaces are close
enough then there's a circle of points
at which this copy of BC's over in that
direction and this copy of meeseeks over
in that direction and so we can compare
that the pattern of temperature
fluctuations be in on those two circles
should be correlated they would be
exactly the same except for there's all
sorts of effects that make them
different like the fact that light has
to travel between from last scattering
surface to us and that changes that that
also induces fluctuations the fact that
the material on this surface
is moving and so there's a Doppler
effect which will have different
contributions to this circle and this
circle but the dominant contribution to
the fluctuation of the temperature
fluctuations on this circle are what's
called the Sachs wolf effect which is
that you have to climb out of the
gravitational potential or that is on
that surface in order to get to us and
that gravitational potential will be the
same around this circle and this circle
still would be a pattern of fluctuations
that I can look at and compare blank
copies so if if my copy is too far away
the last scattering surfaces don't
intersect I won't find any circles so
what I have to do is I have to go out
and look at all circles of the same size
and compare the patterns around them and
we'll talk about that in a minute
and it was shown by Jeff weeks who's a
student of Bill Thurston's very
accomplished apologist of his own right
that if you find the pattern of circle
pairs it's unique if there's a unique
correspondence between those and the
manifold okay so you know actually know
what space you look well so it'll turn
out ask me that question later remember
that question that's complete so I've
told you that we might be able to look
for topology but the question is why
bother well one reason is because we can
it would be really interesting to
discover the topology the universe but I
wanna I want to suggest some further
reasons
so let's come back to this idea that
that we calculate the angular power
spectrum so here is from 2013 what the
angular power spectrum would would have
looked like you know it's it's
to this amazing we complicate you know
complicated set of points that are fit
by this six parameter and I would argue
actually seven parameter fit that
there's no such thing as the six
parameter fit in this case but to the
way more than six points right and so
this is is pretty remarkable and of
course it's not just that power spectrum
which was the temperature power spectrum
there also cross power spectral power
spectrum and I think I put here the
cross power spectrum between temperature
and polarization so way more than six
points being fit or seven points being
fit by just seven parameters it's this
that more than anything you know drove
us to where we now have many zeros in
our in our plus and minuses in a field
that you know before this would have
been worried about 20-percent effects or
fifty percent of X or factor of five
effects so astonishing experimental
accomplishment and a remarkable
agreement with theory especially for
statistics like the one I just looked at
that the theory prefers but there's a
big button and that but one of those
butts at least comes when looking at the
large angles or the low helps and so I
want to tell you about several of the
ways in which the lowest l's
the largest angle properties of the
Cosmic Microwave Background aren't
fitting into this story quite as
beautifully as you would like and I want
to start doing that by looking at Ciel's
about this angular power spectrum and
pointing out things that are anomalous
so I want to start by pointing out
something that everyone said is
anomalous and really isn't but it is how
I think people initially got started so
that my animation died that says the low
quadrupole
so there's there's this but see chu
seems to be quite low so if you're if
you're not used to seeing CMB plots this
is the measured angular power spectrum
those sisa bells this line is the best
fit from the theory this curve and and
you can see the the just great band
around that and that's that's the
uncertainty
induced by cosmology by the fact that we
only get to measure 2 L plus 1 ALM of
each L ok so up here at all equals 200
that means we get 400 estimators of the
value of C 200 but down here at l equals
2 we get 5 chances to measure C 2 and so
we don't do it we don't expect to do a
very good job and we'd like to measure
this number was it bubble will have an
error bar this big but nevertheless this
number is small the quadrupole is small
and that's exactly and that's okay
exactly
ya know who cares right um but it was
the first thing people one of the first
things people said oh that's kind of odd
why is it why is it so small there is
something there is another thing in the
CLS down though at Lowe's logos which is
kind of odd if you notice so here is l
equals 2 and then L equals 3 is above it
I think was for those five is above it
illegal 6 and that little 7 is above it
a 9 is above it
10 11 is above it 12 13 is above at 14
15 is about but 16 seconds by the 1890s
above it so for some reason it always
goes up right the odd ones are stronger
than the even ones and according to the
theory there is no correlation between
among these among these else
okay here here is more of that angular
power structure we focused on the cell
equals two before but there's actually
others that are even more anomalous okay
there's this this dip in the first peak
this this other dip it up about 20 the
splits at L of 40 so you know we could
sit here and figure out how often this
should happen but here's something
really strange that that was in the very
first W map want first-year paper the
very first version of their paper about
the angular power spectrum but that
disappeared from all future versions
this figure in which that this curve has
been separately calculated over the part
of the sky near the ecliptic plane the
plane of the solar system and at the
part of the sky perpendicular to the
plane so the ecliptic poles and what
you'll notice is that that dip at 20
that glitch at 40 and that dip and the
first peak are all in the ecliptic polar
regions and in fact what we've shown is
that this one turns out to be
exclusively near the ecliptic North Pole
so these are you know how significant
are these I'm not going to go into the
details of that this all of this is
what's called a pasti or e statistics
which means I go look at these things
after I already have the data no one I
didn't tell you I was gonna look at them
should I have looked at them should they
have not have looked and what penalties
should I do pay for doing that it's not
clear
so let me tell you some other that's
that is if we look at these CC bells
remember the theory told me the only
thing that's interesting is calculating
the angular power spectrum and measuring
it because the universe is statistically
isotropic it doesn't matter what
individual a LM s are it only maverick
matters what the average of their square
is so I want to ignore that and ask and
this came out of think you're trying to
think of ways of looking for topology
but I want ask a different question is
which is what are the directions
associated with the house multiple in
other words if instead of summing over L
and M when this spherical harmonic what
if I just sum over m and and that makes
sense because the universe is supposed
to be statistically isotropic and so
each L kind of is independent these are
the things these a LM s are the ones
that contribute to a particular C sub L
and for l equals one
in fact we rarely think of a 1 M a 1 0
and a 1 - when we think of what's called
the dipole which is some vector which
has some magnitude in the direction
okay so instead of writing a 1 M 0 and
minus 1 we write some strength of the
dipole and some direction of the dipole
dotted into the unit vector and that's a
better way of thinking of the dipole in
some ways because this you had is a
vector it's really a pseudo vector but
it's ok and a is a scalar under
rotations and so C 1 and a 1 all it
depends is only a 1 depends on C 1 so
measuring a 1 is the same as measuring C
1 now you can do the same things at
higher al you can think of l equals 2 is
the product of two dipoles L equals 3 is
product with three dipoles etc you
should be careful and subtract out all
the traces but you can replace the 2 L
plus the 2 L plus 1 al MS
but L unit vectors and a scale and the
point is that those those L unit vectors
are vectors that a is a scalar and the
only thing that's supposed to be
interesting is that scalar the the
directions of all these dipoles what are
called multiple vectors are supposed to
be completely uninteresting according to
our theory we were very excited when we
invented this this way of representing
data on the sphere and said until
someone pointed out that it had been
done before you may have heard of him
his name is Maxwell and he wrote this
it's not very important book and this is
how he thought of AB data on the sphere
as products of L directional derivatives
of the one over R potential on the unit
sphere this is just it's just another
way of representing instead of spherical
harmonics it's another way of
representing data on the sphere so the
quadrupole can be represented by two
vectors in other words you can think of
it the quadrupole as a plane and the
octupole by three back there is instead
of none as you can think of it as a
solid or as three planes and so you can
think of what we call the area vectors
which just are the areas of those
planets so their normals to those planes
and those are an interesting way to
think of it so what I want to show you
is the area of actors of the quadrupole
and octupole and I'm going to do is in
this really weird projection because
that's how we always did it and and that
way I'm not I no one can claim that I'm
you know trying to change things up to
make it look better okay so here here is
the area of actors so remember the
quadrupole is a plane the octupole is
three planes and the quadrupole and
octupole according to our theory are
completely independent okay so these
should point in random directions all
right so here and I plotted in both the
northern southern hemisphere you knows I
don't know whether to point my normal
vector this way or this way so here is
the normal vector to the quadrupole in
dark in
rakesh gray and here are the oops here
are the three vectors of these vectors
of the octupole in in in dark block so
up here it's hard to see them because
this really is somewhere over here so
here they are let's look in the southern
hemisphere here are the three octupole
vectors here's the quadrupole vector so
they should have been distributed
everywhere in this southern hemisphere
but they're all clustered around and
that really is a pretty small region for
them to be clustered in you'll notice
that there's a another dot there that's
actually the dipole the direction of D
of the Earth's motion through the
through the microwave background there's
this dashed line here and I'm going to
stick in all the all the things that we
could imagine would be affecting the
experiment and so all the all the
astronomical directions are planes that
might have been contaminating the
experiment and costing systemic so
there's ecliptic which is the plane of
the orbit that the experiment was in
that whether it's W map or Planck the
dipole which is the direction of the
Earth's motion through the CMB
approximately the equinoxes I have no
idea why we put that on there this super
galactic plane I'm not sure why that
should matter but someone told us to put
it on there okay and so um what do you
see you see that these are all clustered
together and maybe that they're near the
dipole and the dipole happens to be near
the ecliptic so maybe they're also near
the ecliptic plane so what we can say is
that these four planes the plane to the
quadrupole the plane of the octupole
three planes of the octupole are for
some reason aligned with one another
there's for some reason essentially
perpendicular to the ecliptic and there
for some reason normal to the dipole
I don't know if any of these are which
of these are important it's hard to
imagine that anything but but
systematics would be responsible for
these last two so if these are important
then that says that this is all
systematics on the other hand say that
the quadruple an octupole we were
bettering the CMB which was supposed to
be there are actually caused by
systematics in the experiments and the
different experiments have the same
systematics how good are these
alignments
well the quarter Pole and octuple Plains
are as aligned with each other depending
on the map that you use somewhere
between you know one a thousand times
and you know in one in 150 times okay
those once those quadruple adoptable
Plains are as these four planes are is
aligned with each other asking how often
are they this perpendicular to the
ecliptic Oh somewhere between 0.2 and 2%
of the time once the quadrupole and
octuple planes are is aligned with each
other and this parent there's this
perpendicular ecliptic how often are
they as aligned as they are to the
dipole Oh a few percent of the time so
and let me leave out the watch things
it's it's less interesting I don't know
if I can multiply these together I don't
know what you these two believe but what
we do see is that the lowest ELLs are
not behaving as though they are
statistically isotropic
and here's here's a nice picture of them
okay so what I've done is like this is
actually just the quadrupole and I'm
showing you what different maps were
different Planck and W map maps have for
these bees not these area vectors for
the quadrupole you'll notice that
they're always tightly clustered all
right which just says that no matter
whether you've got you this with W map
are you mad at you with Planck no matter
what method you use to clean your map to
take out the four grounds no matter what
method you used to to heal in the fill
the galaxy you get the same answer it
does not seem to be so if it's
systematics it's some deep systematics
okay and the same thing is true of the
optical none of this matters it's also
interesting and I don't show this here
that when we when we realized that we
needed to subsist so that we believed
that the dipole of the CMB is due to our
motion through the universe okay and
everyone knows to subtract and therefore
not to look at the dipole it's not
interesting it's not cosmology it's just
the Earth's motion through the universe
probably but people haven't been worried
about the fact that that would actually
contribute to the quadrupole and when we
when we subtracted the Doppler
contribution to the quadrupole that
pulled the quadrupole and octupole
vectors together much more tightly
so what are the conclusions about that
well these alignments are persistent
they're individually interesting
collectively significant we have no good
no good explanation for them just
something else really strange about that
low L stuff the quadruped not just the
quadrupole talk before so as you pointed
out who cares about a low quadrupole but
isn't actually what's strange about
these low elves it really should be
called the large angle in homer and
here's why so before
Kobe which was the original all-sky
measurement of the microwave background
back in the 1990s the cosmic background
Explorer astronomers weren't dismissed
at an angular power spectrums spectra
they were interested in angular
correlation functions and so when Kobe
was proposed they thought they were
going to go out and measure the angular
correlation function which is take the
temperature at any two directions that
are separated by some angle theta and
multiply them an average over all pairs
of directions like that on the sky and
that's the angular correlation function
and the thing is that you can exchange
the information the angular correlation
function for the information in the
angular power spectrum and our theory
tells us what that's much better to
calculate the angular power spectrum
because the C sub ELLs are statistically
independent and clearly receive it and
if that's true the angular correlation
function at different say this isn't so
it's much the statistics of it is much
more complicated but eventually so but
by the time Coby reported its results
people had realized the theory was much
more interested in the angular power
spectrum and so they mostly didn't tell
us what the angular correlation function
is they finally got around to it in one
of their last papers so here is what it
looks like
what you should notice is that above
about sixty degrees here it seems to be
very close to zero but very little you
know this was noticed I'm not showing
you here what's expected I'll do that in
a second but it was noticed but not
really no one really focused on that so
here from the next good measurement of
that by W map is what the expectation is
that's this dashed line with these kind
of the error bars around them and you
shouldn't think of them as normal error
bars because they're highly correlated
with one another so this is what the
theory tells us is that that the the
data should life kind of in this band
and here's what the data looks like if
you take it from from any of the
individual bands that W map measured
okay so they all sit like this and
notice that just like Kobe they sit here
at zero from about sixty degrees to 170
degrees now if you go ahead and look at
what's reported eventually for the
angular correlation function you see
instead this curve which isn't a zero
that's that's this ILC full okay or the
maximum likelihood estimate don't
something built under the maximum
likelihood estimate that seems to not be
zero okay those are in a process pieces
that's processed information about the
two-point correlation function if you
take the sky map outside of the galaxy
and calculate the two-point correlation
function you'll get this - curved which
agrees with all of the individual bands
and then they have to go ahead and have
to figure out well what is the even
though we don't trust the data in the
galaxy what what do we think the data in
the galaxy is essentially it's much more
much more it's much much more rigorous
than that but when you put in what you
know what you think the full sky is and
then calculate the two-point correlation
function you get something that has
correlations between 60 degrees
170 degrees so you measure no
correlations but then you infer a
correlations it's very strange
so that means you find up there and
measure the temperature the air and it's
probably it is a bit hotter that's a bit
more no it's not anti-correlated
it's uncorrelated I have for measuring
it there I get no information about
there yeah once those are more than 60
degrees apart great question
I'll tell you in a minute so this you
know one measure of that is this
property s 1/2 which is just integral
from 60 degrees 180 degrees of C of
theta squared so it's it's not that this
it's not that this curve which ever
these curves lie so far outside of these
broad error bars it's not zero it's very
strange
and the theory didn't the theory told us
this wasn't an interesting thing to a
question to ask but when you ask it you
find that the answer doesn't agree with
the theory so this is persisted in all
of the cuts guy maps with p-values of
you know point oh four percent so that's
four times ten to the minus four point
oh four percent point oh two percent you
know point oh two percent the full sky
maps will have five percent but the cuts
guy maps the parts that exclude the
galaxy it'll be like point oh two point
oh four percent
and it'll turn out that all of the
correlations pretty much from sixty 175°
come from pairs of points at least one
of which is inside the galaxy so if you
tap both points outside the galaxy no
correlations but if you start putting
points inside the galaxy then you start
to see correlations did this change in
plank no so this is a property of the
sky that we see apparently not a
property of the experiment that we're
doing so somewhere between 0.03 and
point one percent of realizations of the
model inflation have so little cup sky
large angle corian relations now if you
ask the question what does this mean for
the angular power spectrum hmm one how
would you get no two-point correlations
we'll remember that
see if theta is sum over L Z sub L Y L
of cos theta and so one way to get to
see if they did to be zeros to set Z sub
L equal to zero well except that's not
what we see so what's happening instead
actually is that those low ll CLS are
cancelling among each other in this
series
and that's really hard to see if you
look at the angular power spectrum but
when you do the Legendre transform and
to see if theta you see that there is
something strange that the C sub ELLs
are are correlated with one another in a
way that's completely unexpected in
lambda-cdm in fact it's really really a
very big puzzle in lambda-cdm because
even if we replaced all of our
theoretical sisa bells by their measured
values so let's just say okay I don't
know how but I'm gonna change the theory
to equal the measurements and take that
as my new theory and now I go ahead and
I take the a LMS which are Gaussian
random variables but now with thee with
those CC bells you'd think I would get
back know two-point correlation function
but I don't and I don't because of
cosmic variance I don't because when I
picked those Gaussian random variables I
don't recover the theoretical C sub L is
like recover the theoretical C spells
plus those big wide error bars and that
means that they don't cancel with each
other in the way that they're supposed
to and so if I do that there's only
about a 3% chance that I will get as
little correlation as I do in the sky
that I see and when you go and look at
those almost always it's because they
all got all the CC bells happen to come
out low so you almost never get what we
see on the sky so how did this happen it
could be a fluke
that's that's the simplest explanation
we just happen to live in an odd you
know an odd realization of lambda-cdm or
it could be physics well if it's physics
how what would that mean it would mean
that one thing it could mean is that the
if we want to keep this idea that the
underlying processes are Gaussian it
would mean that the basis we're using is
the wrong basis to be Gaussian so I
don't know of any other explanation so
how could that come about one way is
that the universe has non-trivial
topology because that means that the
modes I use were the wrong modes another
way that is that maybe and this is this
seemed to be completely reasonable
maybe I don't actually have long
distance correlations we can think of a
Fourier mode a thorium mode is really
strange it has infinite distance
correlations if I give you a Fourier
mode and I tell you it's value here and
I tell you what K it has I can tell you
its value anywhere so that's infinite
length correlations that seems weird
maybe the real things are more like
wavelets they look like Fourier modes
but after some point they kind of decay
away and what we we thought that was a
really good explanation it just turns
out not to work for interesting reasons
let me tell you about one more thing
that's really odd about the large angle
universe and I'll come back and finish
with how this is related apology so here
is here is the sky actually I think this
is probably this is a later sky than
that but this is uh one thing you might
notice about this guy if you look at it
it's a lot kind of busier here it so
what's more there's more power down here
than up here and that was first noticed
by bending it all on 2003 and there's
some papers by Ericsson 2004 many many
people have noticed this it's usually
described as the dipole asymmetry you
notice this this dipole in power you
know strong power ear weak power here
I'd actually think that's the wrong way
to describe it and it turns out that if
we use the High Elves and you can't
really see here to predict what the low
L skies should be but this guy should
look like damn here it's just right it's
doing exactly what it's supposed to be
and up here it's not so if I look at
characterizes I can characterize this by
the variance in the north and the south
in the south so here is the probability
distribution function for the variance
on half the sky and the South's it's you
know right in right near the the mode of
the distribution right near the median
of the distribution it's completely
ordinary and the north sits down here
you know with only 0.1% of realizations
below it this is the variance in some
units it's not in arbitrary units of
this of the temperature okay so this is
the the temperature variance on the
south it's gone or the sky
south is normal the north is really
strange how strange well about one of
the thousand skies have this little
variance in one of their hemispheres
so with so many anomalies what do we do
we go measure things about the northern
sky so the ecliptic is not the perfect
cut you can make the cut a little bit
better yeah so that you so you can ask
what you know what what there's always
in all of these things there's a paucity
or a statistics and that's why what's
really interesting is what how do you go
check that these are real as opposed to
flukes and and that's another talk yeah
Gordo about 21% is that doing a
simulation that may be the best possible
cut and asked that was that was not
marginalizing over over hemispheres that
was asking North versus South yeah
that's asking how often is a hemisphere
that low so it's Emma's curves define
the same way yeah
taking atmosphere ask a lot often is it
that low okay so what does this have to
do with topology which is supposed to be
the topic of this talk so here is a
paper from 2009 by BL Levitch Andrea's
well mo what they said is suppose the
universe has one small dimension its
compact in one of the dimensions and
they looked using multiple vectors at
the quadrupole and octupole so this this
is what that universe would look like it
had two dimensions that are large
compared to last gathering surface and
in one dimension it was small and what
they found was that typically they would
have quadruples and octupole z-- that
were planar in a line in the way that we
see okay now they couldn't they could it
wasn't it was statistically favorite but
it wasn't enough to rule out you know
the universal covering space rule there
was no topology but it was it was
favorite
so last year we looked at very similar
things that are called slab topologies
and we showed that if our universe is
flat and has one compact dimension of
appropriate size this would suppress the
large angle the the angular correlation
function from 60 degrees up if you chose
it to be the right size as you adjust
the size you would change the range of
angles over which you suppress it while
maintaining a low an angular power
spectrum consistent with observations
and seven others it wouldn't set the C
house to 0 it would arrange for this
conspiracy now the only problem with
this was that both of these conflict
with existing limits so remember I told
you about the circles and how we could
search for the for the further topology
with the circles and we've done that we
did that we started we did that first in
the early 2000s and then we went and did
it better so here is us looking for with
some statistic asks for 4 circles in
some universe that someone gave us a
tree as wellö gave us he didn't tell us
what it was he just said I you know here
here is here is a sky doesn't have
circles and we said well it has circles
that have that have angular great
angular radii of 70 degrees you know 63
degrees 61 degrees etc we found all
these all these places where it had
circles and he said well you did pretty
well you're false negative rate was you
know less than 0.02 percent for all
circles that were you know that we were
bigger than 42 degrees and 2 percent
once they were once they were 24 degrees
so we're pretty good at finding circles
and when we looked in W map we didn't
find it and then when the Planck team
looked they use the circle search they
use something they but they didn't you
do the proper circle search they only
did you looked at circles that were back
to back where this is you really have to
look at pairs the circles that are in
arbitrary directions on the skies so we
did we don't find circles we don't find
circles all the way down to yeah all the
way down actually from from ten degrees
all the way up to I'm not sure we up to
eighty degrees and also set your
separations from back to back all the
way down to 11 degrees yeah yeah and so
that tells us that the shortest path
around the universe is greater than
ninety eight point five percent of last
scattering surface which rules out those
those slab topologies with the size that
that seem to seem to explain things one
point diameter of certainty the size was
point seven times of a module a
scattering surface rocks
quite seven and we ruled that point not
up to point nine eight
so does that leave us the large angle
CMB is extremely anomalous cosmic
topology maybe why but it's not a simple
slab topology there's work to be done in
looking at other topologies because it
turns out that there's all sorts of
things very like the slab topology that
aren't ruled out by the circle searches
or by the mode mode searchers and
there's measurements to be made to see
if some of these anomalies are
statistical flutes or if they have
physics behind them thanks
you